[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing none other than hogwarts
keeper of keys and grounds
rubius hagrid more specifically we're
going to be honing in on one peculiar
aspect
of hagrid's character his wand or lack
thereof
if you had never noticed before which
i'm quite certain is impossible
hagrid doesn't have the traditional ones
that one might expect a witch or wizard
to have
it's not a banana and it's not a
toothbrush but it isn't far off
it's an umbrella ordinarily umbrellas
possess one very simple function
stop rain from falling on your head
however hagrid seems to be able to do
just a few more things with his umbrella
and what i want to look at today
is a why hagrid has an umbrella wand
and b how his umbrella wand works
first things first why it all starts
with hagrid's schoolboy days
hagrid began attending hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry
near 1940 and assorted into gryffindor
house
starting just two years after voldemort
himself
who was a promising young wizard but did
have a habit of getting into trouble
trouble which almost always stemmed or
pertained to magical creatures in some
way
it just so happened that hagrid attended
the school during a bit of a crazy
period
for you see salazar sullivan's basilisk
had been released and was petrifying
students
how students were being petrified was a
complete mystery but a witch hunt
or wizard hunt eventually ensued in
order to find the culprit
unfortunately for hagrid due to his
affinity for magical creatures
he was effectively framed for the crimes
and barred from hogwarts
he was expelled from the school no
longer allowed to practice magic
and his wand was snapped the only good
thing going for hagrid was that
dumbledore stuck up for him
and got him a position as the school's
game keeper but did hagrid let all of
that stop him
certainly not and this is why he ended
up with the magical umbrella
that allowed him to perform the same
magic that he always did
at least nearly the same magic with that
established now let's get into the how
in essence hacker's umbrella was
constructed using pieces of his broken
wand
they were concealed inside as to not
draw any tension since hagrid was barred
from magic
but the umbrella seems to go by
relatively unnoticed
one thing you might be wondering however
is how hagrid's umbrella
was at all effective historically when a
wand is broken
it effectively becomes unreliable and
useless so what made hagrid's umbrella
many different
think of say ron weasley's broken wand
for instance
here's the thing about hagrid's wand it
may be constructed out of lots of little
pieces of wand
but he did a better job at mending it
than most others
harry potter tried to jerry-rig his wand
and ron's wand was speller taped
together
hagrid's wand was built into the handle
of his umbrella and supported with a
splint
so it stands to reason that the good
craftsmanship may contribute
to the ones capabilities the last thing
to consider is that ones are
quasi-sentient
and that the relationships that ones
form with wizards are strong
it could just be that hagrid's ones had
a particular affinity for the
happy-go-lucky giant
which is white ended up working better
than it perhaps should have
did you guys ever think about this let
me know in the comment section
below until next time remember if you
want to know what a man's like
take a good look at how he treats his
inferiors not his equals
you